how'd it right back when you have to say
no so recently made a video called right
back where i encouraged people to on
their social media channels and people
write to you to write back we're just
this kind of common decency and one of
my youtube viewers love you guys sharing
wrote in to say good video what is your
advice to running back when you have to
say no or that you don't like something
I find it easier to respond when it's a
nice thing by harder when it's not how
can I stay positive in these responses
without seeming insincere thanks again
love these videos sharing so share this
a great question and I tend to lump
these kind of incoming communications in
the four categories okay the first one
is your fans and these are the these are
the ones that you love responding to
these are the the positive comments is
there what motivates me every day when I
wake up and turn my computer and I'm
eating my lentils for breakfast and I
see your comments coming in that the
fans are supporting you and and just
doing that just responding to the
positive ones already puts you ahead of
most people which is shocking it blows
my mind it's shocking but just doing
that I can't tell how many people I've
written to on Twitter or commented on
YouTube video and say just saying hey
great stuff congratulations you know
love your book love your video great
points whatever and and you hear nothing
back I get not nothing I don't know I'm
used to responding to people and just
doing that seems like a basic thing for
me anyway respond to your fans okay
number one number two is going to be
your your haters the little man the
people who who nitpick at the stuff
you're saying who find faults with
everything we're trying to poke holes in
your argument who just hate instead of
making something great and in doing
something good with their lives they
focus on negativity and tearing other
people down and unfortunately there's a
lot of these people in the world and
that's up to you now did you respond
they're not up to you you know typically
what I'll do is I'll tender respond
and I'll try to turn them around and
sometimes it happens and sometimes it
doesn't and if I'm in the emails a
couple emails deepen and they're not
changing and you're not understanding
then I'll let it drop but i'll usually
respond a couple times just to try to
bring them back you know don't be so
negative man like don't focus so much on
the specific words we focus on the idea
and do something positive with your life
a lot of times it's just helping them
see that they have potential you know
they could do something great and and
nobody has ever believed in them
probably in their whole life and so
they're so negative but it's optional
you know what you don't be surrounded by
negative people don't respond the third
group are the spammers spammers and I
get so many emails that are you know
dear Michael love your website we have a
great promotional offer for you you can
sell your audience our great pet food
it's like are you kidding me really like
did you even look at my website you even
know my name do you look at who I serve
are you kidding me do a little bit of
research spammers whatever that gets
deleted that's not going to get a
response and then the fourth are the
group of people who you have to let down
you know the ones you say no too often
I'll get people right into me and you
know I value my time okay I have a lot
of stuff on the go a lot of projects i'm
working on tons of stuff and I value my
time and I can't say yes to everybody
right I can't say yes to everybody but I
don't want to just ignore people and so
people right into me and they want me to
review their book or they want me to
speak at an event or they want me to
I'll get a lot people say hey can you
can you call me can we have an hour
phone call to talk about something like
I don't I I would love to but I don't
have that time I can't do that right
otherwise I'd just be bombarded as too
much and so you can think about but what
I'll do is I'll think about an
alternative right if somebody wants me
to call them say well I can make a video
response for you if you have a specific
question and let them know I don't have
time to call everybody individually
or if they want me to review their book
and I just don't have time for it i'll
say you know what I love to I appreciate
it thank you for thinking of me but I
just have too much on my plate right now
good luck with the project so I'm being
honest you know like I want their thing
to succeed I just don't have the time
right or don't have the interest it's
not a fit for what I'm doing right now
and so if you are you know you're you're
still positive and that you appreciate
them for reaching out to you you're
still positive and that you're wishing
them good luck with whatever they're
trying to do you know hopefully they're
doing something important and give them
the best wishes but you let them know
that you can't help out right now you
know you don't have to tack them you
have to say hey that book that's that's
a that's a crappy idea I don't want any
part of it say thank you for thinking of
me I've got just way too much on the go
right now good luck with the book right
that's a lot nicer more positive vibes
being sent out than having to slam
somebody so those are the four types of
people who write into me and how I
respond and hopefully that helps you
believe for those of you watching like
the video let me know how you deal with
these people leave a comment below if
you liked this video you can click on
the support me link in the description
and click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon